FRANCIS MA: Welcome
to our session on Grow
your app with Google identity.
My name is Francis Ma and I'm a
product manager on the Google+
platform team.
JENNIFER LIN: My
name is Jennifer Lin,
and I'm the engineering lead
on the Google+ platform team.
FRANCIS MA: So today
we're going to be sharing
10 insights with you guys on
how you can grow and engage
your audience via Google.
These insights or actionable,
they're easy to implement,
and they help you tap into
the array of Google platform
services ranging from things
like search, Google+, YouTube,
and more.
So let's get started.
JENNIFER LIN: All right.
Oftentimes when users
are looking for something
they start on Google search.
This makes Google search
a prominent entry point
for users.
As developers, you're looking
to grow your audience.
So some of you may want
to get more visibility
on Google search.
Well, our very
first insight helps
you increase
visibility in search
so you can be
discovered more easily.
All you have to do is create
a Google+ page and post fresh
content about your service.
Then Google search will show
your content on the right hand
side when users search
for your service.
As you can see, GQ
Magazine already does this.
This is actually really easy for
you to do, no engineers needed.
So think of your Google+ page
as your brand's home on Google.
Using your Google+ page you
can directly control what brand
content shows up on the
Google search results page.
This is a really
great way for you
to drive traffic to your
website from Google Search
and you'll reach a lot more
people through Google search.
FRANCIS MA: So that
was a really easy way
to get your brand identity
more visible in search.
Another insight is
about app indexing,
which you may have heard
earlier today at the keynote.
So let's talk about a
problem that some of you
might have as app developers.
When users install
your app oftentimes
you may find it hard
to re-engage the users,
to keep them sticky,
to come back.
And this problem gets worse,
especially as users install
more and more apps
and your app might
have been pushed to say the
fifth page of the App Launcher.
So even though you
might try to come up
with new updates, new
content, oftentimes the users
may just not remember and may
not be coming back to your app.
And app indexing is a good
way to solve this problem.
So what app indexing does,
it lets you create deep links
from Google search
into your native app.
So as you see on an
example on the screen
there, when I search
for, let's say,
a movie review, because
I have IMDB installed now
Google search shows
me, hey you can
view this content in IMDB app.
And when I tap on that I get
deep linked right into the app.
Now as native app developers
this is particularly important
because you might have
unique experiences
in the native environment
that you otherwise would not
have on your mobile website.
So app indexing is
really a good way
to help bring that users from
search, which is typically
where they start to
look for content,
and bring that back
into your native app.
Another feature
with app indexing
that was mentioned
earlier in the keynote
is the app indexing
API, which also
lets you programmatically
index your content
as users are viewing
them or consuming them
in your native app.
And by using the
app indexing API,
Google search can also show
this user's app history
in the instant
search suggestions.
So for example,
if I was searching
for "It's a Wonderful
Life" movie, as I
type I-T-S Google
would automatically
suggest to complete the search
history because I'm already
an existing user of your app.
So this is a really good way
to help drive engagement.
Another benefit of using app
indexing is that you would,
as part of the setup process,
you would have your website
and also create a listing
in the Google Play store.
Now when you have a
listing on the Google Play
store with your native
app, Google search
would then also
automatically index that
and provide another way for
users to discover your app.
So even though users
may not necessarily
be browsing or searching from
within the Google Play store
you now have another vector
for users to discover your app.
Switching gears a bit,
we talked about how easy
it was for you to integrate
with search, another problem
that you might have is driving
cross-platform engagement
and growing your users
across these platforms.
Now some of you might have
been in business for many years
and have been developing
apps starting on the web
and now as users are
spending more time on mobile
you're making this pivot.
But the problem is
you've invested a lot
to get your audience
on the web and now when
you pivot to mobile
it's like starting
from scratch all over again.
The app distribution
dynamics are
very different in the
native app stores,
and to have to restart from
that it's oftentimes costly.
So the good news is we have
an easy way to help you.
The third insight that we're
sharing with you today is
to integrate Google+ Sign-In.
Now Google+ sign in lets
your users very easily sign
in to your website without
having to remember another
credential.
So they can use
their Google account
and log in to your site.
Now what's special
about that is,
because they use
their Google account
we can also figure out whether
they're an Android user
and have your app installed.
In this example you see
on the screen with Fitbit,
when user doesn't
have the app installed
and I login, what I
see is a prompt for me
to download the Fitbit app.
And if I say yes the app
gets installed automatically
on my native phone.
So this happens
in the background
while I'm still on the
website and engaging.
The user can continue
to resume their session
and do their thing
on your website,
but then later on when
you switch to mobile,
they would have your
app ready to go.
So this is not like at a later
time, they don't have to fiddle
and figure out, oh,
what was that app again?
I have to search for
it in Play store,
wait a couple
minutes to download.
They have it right there
and then, ready to jump it.
And because users
are very engaged,
they've expressed an intent
to engage on your website,
driving this app install
we've seen very good results.
As an example, one of our
partners, Deezer-- some of you
might know it's a music
streaming service,
they've seen that on
average 33% of users
convert when prompted to
install their mobile app.
So if you contrast that to
something like a mobile app
install ad, you might get
single digits or maybe even
lower conversion rates.
With this you get 33% conversion
rates and best of all,
it's free.
So Deezer gets really
good results as a result
from integrating Google Sign-In.
Now also because we show this
installation prompt at the time
when user has engaged
with your website,
the referral is a very
high quality user.
It's not just somebody who has
accidentally clicked on an add
or might have heard
about your service.
This is somebody who's already
engaged with your website
and now are
redirected to mobile.
For Deezer, the
result they see is
that when users
sign in with Google
and they download
the app, they're
twice as more likely to
upgrade to their account.
So this not only helps you
with the app discovery,
but also helps with the
monetization story as well.
Lastly, because with Google+
sign in it's easier for users
to sign in without having
to remember another log
in and password, they've seen
a reduction in sign in drop off
rates.
JENNIFER LIN: So you just saw
how Google+ sign in can give
you quality Android
app installs.
Now when users open
your Android app,
we wanted to make sure they
get a seamless experience,
so we automatically
sign in your users
with their Google account
on your Android app.
Let's take a look at
9Gag as an example.
9Gag.com is a
social media website
that lets users upload
and share images.
After users sign in
to 9Gag's website
and install the Android
app over the air,
they're automatically signed in
when they start 9Gag's Android
app and they're greeted
with a welcome back toast.
So let's think about
how this insight can
help you grow your
audience across platforms.
Let's say you're building
an e-commerce website
and mobile app and you notice
your users are abandoning
their shopping cart
on your website.
So what can you do to
increase purchase conversions?
Well, since sign in with
Google automatically
logs in users on your website
and mobile app across devices,
you can help those users when
they're in your mobile app
continue from
where they left off
so they can finish
their purchase.
Let's take another example.
Let's say you're
building a news service.
And your users are reading
articles in your mobile app,
but they don't finish because
their bus ride comes to an end.
Later on they're
on their laptop,
browsing your news website.
Well here you can
help those users pick
up from where they left off
by showing them the article
they didn't finish
reading earlier.
So these are just
a few examples,
but you can apply
this best practice
to other services
you may be building,
like a hotel booking service.
And remember any user
with a Google account
will get this seamless
sign in experience.
And Google accounts include
Gmail users, Google+ users,
Android users, YouTube
users, et cetera.
Fancy is one of our partners
who integrated Google sign
in earlier last year.
And we have a quote from
Andrew, the executive VP
of operations at Fancy.
He said that "users
who were signed
in through Google
more profitable."
We also want to share with
you their integration results.
Fancy saw that users
who sign in with Google
spend 14% more than other users.
And those users helped increase
purchase conversion by 20%.
So for more case studies
from our other partners
you can visit this link
at developers.google.com.
FRANCIS MA: So we
just talked about ways
to get more visibility
in the search
and driving more app
installs and connecting users
across platform.
Another problem
that you might face
is when users first
experience your website,
how do you help create a
more engaging experience?
Now of course, you guys
know that a lot of websites
are just another click away.
It's very easy for them to
download your competitor's app
and just go on from there.
So really captivating
that first time experience
is very important.
And with Sign-In with
Google one of the things
you get is the ability to
request for the user's profile
information for things like
name, email, contacts, circles,
et cetera.
So with this you can
do a couple things.
First, for new users
for the on-boarding flow
you can make that much simpler.
Instead of having to go through
the laborious process of having
to fill in the user
name, et cetera,
you can pre-populate
a lot of these things.
As Alexandra here on this
website, she arrives,
she's ready to go.
Another thing you
can do with some
of the social data like
contacts and circles,
is that you can create a more
engaging social experience.
So for things like if you
have a public oriented service
like a community forum you can
use that to also show people
that Alexandra
might be connected
with, friends of
hers, et cetera, who
are using the service to then
also tailor that experience.
Instead of just showing the
cookie cutter welcome message,
you might now show,
oh hey, by the way
your friend Bob and
Jane are here and here
are some of the other content
that they've generated.
So being able to
capture the user
to make them easier to on
board to your website and also
present a more engaging,
personalized experience.
It's really good thing.
JENNIFER LIN: So once you get
users engaged in your apps
that's personalized
just for them,
you should convert these
users into your advocates
to help you drive viral growth.
And we have the insights
to help you do this,
and also to help you reach users
across the surface of Google.
What you need to do is
integrate sharing to Google+.
And the key insight here is
to facilitate targeted sharing
to individuals.
Now when users share content
from your website or mobile app
with their friends, you can
pre-fill their recipients
right here on the bottom.
And you can do this by
either using your own data,
or as Francis mentioned
earlier, by getting
the user's list of
friends from Google.
This will make sharing easier
and faster for your users.
Then the share action will
trigger a notification
to all the recipients.
And all the recipients
will see this notification
because the notification icon
is visible across all Google
properties.
So when you enable sharing
to Google+ you can now grow
your users and re-engage them
whenever they are on Google
maps, Google+, search,
YouTube, et cetera.
FRANCIS MA: So as an
alternative to pre-populating
their recipients, you might
not necessarily have the data
or if you don't want to go to
the extent of integrating some
of the other API's
is that you can also
take advantage of
automatic suggestions.
So here's an example of an iOS
app that's integrated share
Google+.
When they choose to
initiate the share,
if there is no
recipient pre-populated,
Google would
automatically suggest
some of the recipients
they can share to.
As an example, let's say I'm a
new user to Google+ and I share
this and I trigger the share.
Now I might not have connected
with anybody yet on Google+,
but I do get a list of
recommended recipients for me.
So my friend Jay, on
the top left there,
is shown because
Google's figured out
that Jay is a close
friend of mine
through our interactions
across Google.
Perhaps I have exchanged a lot
of emails with him recently,
or I might have interacted with
him through YouTube, et cetera.
So Google would
automatically suggest that.
And if I choose not
to use the suggestion,
if there's somebody specific in
mind that I want to share to,
the search feature also
lets the users search
through their local
contacts as well.
So again, even though the
user might be new to Google+,
they can use either the
suggested recipients or through
search to share to people
that they care about.
So of course when the
recipient gets this,
they too get the
notification across Google,
whether it's on Gmail,
drive, et cetera.
So the net takeaway here is
that Google makes sharing easy
and it helps you
grow your audience.
JENNIFER LIN: In addition
to growing and re-engaging
your users via Google+
sharing and notifications,
there are other key channels
of the Google platform that can
help you re-engage your users.
And you can easily access
these channels through Google+
Sign-In.
Let's start with YouTube.
Some of you may have
a YouTube channel,
but for those who don't, here's
why you may want to get one.
Now when users sign in to
your website or mobile app
with their Google
account you can also
ask them to subscribe
to your YouTube channel
as part of the sign in process.
Then the next time
users visit YouTube
they'll see videos
from your channel
alongside other
recommended content.
Your YouTube channel
will also show up
on their subscription list.
And all this leads to
more views on your videos.
Now YouTube has more than one
billion monthly active users
and they spend over six
billion hours watching videos,
so you should really
take this opportunity
to get in front of your users.
Now I'm going to walk you
through a really cool example
that combines this YouTube
subscription insight
and the Google search visibility
insight we talked about earlier
to help you get amazing user
reach across Google search,
YouTube, and your Google+ page.
Let's say you just
released another version
of your mobile app.
Well, you can upload a video
to your YouTube channel that
promotes the latest
mobile app release.
Then you can share this
video on your Google+ page,
and that video post will show
up on the right hand side
of Google search when
users search for your app.
And users who are subscribed
to your YouTube channel
will see that same video
when they visit their YouTube
homepage.
So with these insights you can
now reach users across Google
search, YouTube, and
your Google+ page.
So be creative
with our insights.
Mix and match them to
help you grow your app.
FRANCIS MA: So in the theme
of being creative and thinking
about how you can tap into other
Google channels as touch points
to reach your users,
here's another one.
Now some of you
may have time based
events associated with your app.
Things like you might have
live streaming video events,
or in this specific
example, Flixster
offers movie show times.
Now by using Google+ Sign-In
you can also integrate with
the Google calendar API very
easily and create reminder
events which would then generate
notifications to bring the user
back.
Now they're a couple
things to take note here.
One, is that you are now
creating a separate touch
point with the user when
they are not directly
using your app.
So here's another
good way for you
to re-engage your user
through Google calendar.
The second part is being
able to just use the calendar
infrastructure very
easily and for free.
Now this is particularly
more important
if you're building a mobile web
application where you might not
have access to
push notifications.
So being able to tap
into calendar as a way
to drive timely reminders
and bring your user back
is a really effective feature.
JENNIFER LIN: Let's move
on to other key channels
of the Google Platform that can
help you build your app faster.
Once you've integrated sign
in with Google or Google+ sign
in, you can use Google Drive
to easily store and retrieve
user's data.
Think of Google Drive as the
user's personal hard drive
in the cloud.
You can store anything, a
user's document, photos, song,
et cetera.
And you get 15 gigabytes
of storage space per user
for free.
Now let's say you're building
a photo editor application.
Well you can build
your app faster
with the help of Google Drive,
because Google Drive can
help you handle secure
backups of users' photos,
it can scale with
your application,
and it can sync
photos for you so they
are accessible from any device.
Now you can focus on building
an awesome photo editing
experience and you can leave the
Cloud Storage to Google Drive.
FRANCIS MA: So we have just
covered nine different ways
that you can tap into the
vast array of Google platform
services.
Here's one more.
And this is particularly
interesting for those of you
who are building commerce
apps, because it's
likely to help you
make more money.
So with the Google Wallet
Instant Buy feature
it would help you access the
user's payment information.
So for example, if the Google
user has purchased content
from Google Play, whether it's
an app that they have paid for,
they've downloaded
a movie, or they're
a subscriber of the Google
Play music All Access,
they would have their payment
information already set up
with Google.
Now when you integrate
the Instant Buy feature
you can use this
account set up and have
that as a way to help
your user check out.
So the experience is
very simple for users.
They get this Buy with Google
option, they tap on that,
you get a confirmation
and then they're done.
They don't have to reenter
their credit card information
because that's already
available through Google.
And of course, if you combine
that with Google+ Sign-In then
you can also make the whole
conversion process very,
very seamless from the initial
time when they want to sign up.
Create an account is a one click
experience for them to log in,
and then to check out
is also very seamless.
So let's look at some of the
results that our partner sees.
Hotel Tonight, some of
you may be familiar,
you can see they're outside
in the showcase area as well.
They have seen really positive
results when they integrated
Google+ Sign-In and Wallet.
So first, once they've
integrated Google+ Sign-In they
have doubled the number
of users that have signed
in on their app.
So again, these
users have now been
moved one step closer to
the check out process.
Another data point is that
when a user is signing in
with Google they are
converting 50% more than users
who use other options.
Again, this is because the
login process is simple
and the fact that oftentimes
their Google account payment
information is already set up.
And lastly is on growth.
We shared with you
several insights
on how you can grow with
Google and Hotel Tonight
has integrated some of these.
And since integrating
Google Sign-In
they've seen a 50% growth
in their Android user base.
JENNIFER LIN: So
we just went over
10 insights that help you
grow and re-engage your users.
Let's do a quick recap.
Google search helps
you drive traffic
to your website and
mobile app so you
can be discovered more easily.
You get quality Android app
installs from Google+ Sign-In
and users are automatically
signed in across multiple
devices to help you grow your
audience across platforms.
You can access the
user's email address,
profile data, contacts,
circles from Google
to help you build a personalized
experience for your users.
Targeted Google+ sharing helps
you reach users across Google.
You can re-engage your
users through YouTube.
With Google Calendar you
get reminder notifications
for free.
Google Drive handles
cloud storage for you
so you can build
your app faster.
And Google Wallet's
Instant Buy helps
you make payment processing
easier with less friction.
Now we have one more insight
for you, it's a bonus insight.
And that is focus on the user
and all else will follow.
Now at the end of the
day none of the insights
that we just gave you will
do you any good unless you
do right by your users.
So think of how you
can apply each insight
to building an awesome
user experience.
Put yourself in
your user's shoes.
If you find the experience
easy to use or helpful then
your users will probably too.
So the message here is focus on
delighting your users so they
love your service, keep coming
back and tell others about it.
FRANCIS MA: There you have it.
That's how you can
grow with Google.
Thank you very much.
And we'd love to
get your feedback.
There's A QR code here.
And also for those
of you who are
interested in doing
a deeper dive on some
of the technical details
on the integrations
we mentioned,
tomorrow morning we're
going to be out in the
Distribute Sandbox.
Some of the engineers
from the platform team,
Google+ platform team will be
there to walk you through some
of the technical details on
integrating across Android,
iOS, and web.
Thank you.
JENNIFER LIN: Thank you
FRANCIS MA: And
we'll hang around
for questions for those
of who want to come by
and we'll hang out here.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]